[Music]
imagine remembering every single day of
your life all in perfect detail for
those with highly superior
autobiographical memory or H Sam for
short this is their reality I remember
everything that's personally happened to
me since I was born
that's Rebecca sharukh I was fascinated
by this condition so I called her up to
find out more hi Rebecca
hi how are you going I'm doing all right
it's very wet Saturday morning here how
are you going side note in this moment I
just realized Rebecca will remember that
this day was a wet morning forever so
you remember everything in great detail
people can remember what they did last
Saturday but I can remember what I did
Saturday 10 years ago what about a
memory from when you out of the baby
when I was 12 days old I was lying down
on the fur car seat in my parents car
and I was staring up at the steering
wheel and I thought what is that Rebecca
is one of only 60 people worldwide to
have been identified with having hate
sin
all through my teenage years I thought
that everybody remembered in this kind
of way I thought it was completely
normal it wasn't until she was 21 when
her parents decided to submit her to the
University of California to undergo two
years of testing after this she was
officially identified as having H Sam
since memories can come to mind
unexpectedly
any time of day a negative memory like
this can make living with HCM difficult
mum was porting me
this Ichi satin dress and I was crying
because I didn't like it and mum gave me
this Minnie Mouse toy and I couldn't say
anything at the time but her face
terrified me but on most days eh Sam as
a gift
Rebecca can recall happy memories and
moments when times get tough a good
memory it makes me so thank all about
having this kind of page so memory
thanks for chatting Rebecca yep
[Music]
[Applause]
to go to a cocktail party and to see an
hors d'oeuvre that has a toothpick
sticking up from it the point of that
toothpick makes me feel shocks of
electricity down the back of my legs
people are perplexed by that my name is
Carolyn Hart
I have mirror-touch synesthesia
mirror-touch synesthesia is a conflation
of the senses the things that you see
are felt on your skin if I see another
person's injuries well I feel that in my
own body if I see someone get touched I
feel that on my skin I'm a massage
therapist I think when mirror-touch
synesthesia has really helped me when
someone tells me what they're feeling in
their body well I feel it in my body and
I think it makes me more able to help
that person every single day I will see
something that triggers waves of pain it
makes it really hard for me to
participate in a lot of contemporary
entertainment like I really love Game of
Thrones and I can't watch the program
because it's so violent I also have
really positive experiences when I watch
ballet I feel my muscles fire when I see
them executing pirouettes I feel like
I'm spinning and that's not an emotional
sense of gee this is really lovely and
so beautiful to watch I feel it in my
body I can't control it if I was to use
my synesthesia I would lose part of
myself that would be irretrievable and
irreplaceable
[Music]
[Music]
by describe it as having bubblegum and
once it's lost all its flavor you have
just a piece of rubber that you chew
over and over again that is essentially
what food is like for me when I put food
into my mouth my name is agent Malik and
I have lost my sense of taste I suffered
a cold and I started getting a metallic
taste in my mouth
once that finally left took my sense of
taste with it it took me a few weeks to
actually identify that it was my taste
because I could smell perfectly I only
eat foods now which spend very little
time in the mouth because I don't
extract any flavor the idea of a
chocolate bar or a steak though where
you chew it in order to bring out the
juices and the flavors of it
there's no enjoyment from it so I find
myself eating very light foods like
salads and rice and also I used the
advantage of adding herbes in order to
make the smell sensation quite enjoyable
I also find these Spice very important
spice is not actually something you
taste it's something you feel it gives
us that sort of tingle in my mouth you
end up with a rather peculiar eating
pattern that people look at you funny
because you're putting chilies on your
breakfast cereal and you've put in a a
mustard sauce I'm pretty much a lot of
the food you eat and almost three years
now we're still not otherwise rooster
why it's gone or getting my sense of
taste back
it's like my world is washed out and I
see fewer shades of color than most
people do so normal people see a million
colors I may see as many as a hundred
million my name is Wendy I'm a producer
at CNN and I am colorblind my name is
Maureen Seberg I'm a tetrachromats and
I'm an author tetrachromacy is the
presence of a fourth kun class in your
retina
if I keep naming my invisible colors
maybe I'll have my own Crayola box one
day when I was in kindergarten my
teacher called my parents because I was
coloring the leaves of my trees and the
trunks of my trees the same color
because I couldn't really see the
difference between green and brown the
only time it was ever overwhelming is a
paint contractor came to my house and
brought no fewer than 32 samples before
I was satisfied that it was a true beige
when I pick out clothes that's hard I
have been known to buy the outfit that
the mannequin is wearing because I know
that that goes together you don't want
to go clothing shopping with me because
the salespeople tell me but it matches
and I can only look at them
sympathetically and keep looking I never
think like oh if I weren't color blind
it would be so much easier to get
dressed in the morning it's just it's
kind of part of me I guess I'm a unicorn
or something
[Music]
what is synesthesia everybody who has it
experiences it in different ways so I
asked a handful of people from around
the world about their experience so
somewhere in my brain the senses get
mixed together when I experience one I'm
also experiencing another that is
completely unrelated what do you mean I
color code numbers in my head so ever
since I was a child I was able to taste
work if I'm in physical pain I
experienced the pain in color and shape
sounds melodies and in fact sound tracks
also has a color to me so what sort of
associations would you make the number
three is blue number three is light blue
three is yellow number six is absolutely
woman four is green two is red 42 it's
green red that's my favorite number
because I like the colors red and green
together but wait it gets weird
for example I love Flashdance songs
she's a maniac is blue one for me but
what a feeling is yellow word people
taste is like meatballs in tomato sauce
Islands as navy blue rectangles moving
from right to left the word English
paste is like a slice of lemon the sound
of a band your face is like Oreos crazy
right but a life without it hmm my life
without synesthesia I don't want to
imagine more empty less would be a lot
more blue world would be very flat and
not as colorful I would be bored
I started painting music just because I
would try to explain synesthesia so many
times it never quite made as much sense
to describe it verbally so I thought it
would be best just to put it on canvas
just because I've always been an artist
and it made it much easier for people to
be able to understand it my name is
Willis McCracken and I am a synesthetic
artist synesthesia is a neurological
condition where your brain is basically
cross-wired so certain stimuli will come
in and it'll create the wrong response
in my brain so from me that's listening
to music and it's translated into color
in my head I'm going to paint
superstition by Stevie Wonder I love a
song superstition just because it's
dynamic and funky and just fun and
expressive whenever I start a piece I
have to listen to the song first to even
know what kind of colors I'd like to use
there are some songs that I hate that I
like the way that they look a little bit
like a lot of pop music it can be pink
and purple and you know just all these
fun bright colors but songs not that
good so one of the other I appreciate it
somehow you know you kind of really have
to be in the right vibe to be able to
paint if you're not in the right vibe
you're not gonna make anything good I
think the prettiest onra of music is
jazz music I love blues and golds and
whites and it just seems very pearly and
iridescent a little bit when I listen to
Etta James at last the thing that stuck
out most
it was just her voice at the very
beginning when she goes into the last
then it's just a very bright and but
also warm sort of feeling and very kind
of classic jazzy which jazz music
generally has a very gold and blue sort
of look to it music has always been a
very big part of my life my older
brother is very musical and when I think
back of him playing the guitar for me I
think of the colors of what those
memories are I was always a little
disappointed because I was never very
musically inclined it was really cool to
have a way to bring music into you know
my life in a different sort of way
[Music]